hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pray now we just got
done with fixing up the looking-glass
now we need to go back to my office my
office and finish the rest of the
message that was delivered me but it
wasn't able to be completed as a good
house okay
I didn't mean to do that how you sent a
[ __ ] imma load [ __ ] you I didn't know
that was gonna happen that was a way to
start an episode ah
alright beneath the way we got to get
back to my home base which might mean
let me do something here I've never done
this before I want to come try this oh
yeah I meant to go through the window
there that's definitely the thing that I
wanted to do how how Oh woah woah woah
what was that what was that huh I climb
that gonna climb that I know I could
just whoa who's out there
Oh what is up there hang on I gotta see
this something's up there oh okay yeah
okay gonna pretend like that didn't just
happen I don't want you to panic not
sure well Security's running all over
the place
I'll regret
[Music]
what to go what what
you didn't look outside your own goddamn
door to see if there was anything wrong
over there you just assume that
everything was hunky dokie
and everything was just happy and smiles
out there and as soon as you look out oh
no
mags superficial injuries nothing a
portable medical kit couldn't handle ok
prevent better soon oh I'm gonna be
feeling better as soon as you get on
patient experience questionnaire yeah
shut up shut up shut up shut up I don't
have time for you I love you thank you
schmuck it is oh oh hi
well that's where I just was maybe there
was some important information to be
over there but new oh hi oh hi what the
[ __ ] how did I miss you now what do I
not what I want I wanted to clue you
guys
bluie good ok gonna bash you BAM go whoa
bye ok All Right see ya uh ma'am ok I
guess he's dead then whoa rare parts
I'll take that walk do you whoopee all
right someone's over here and I'm about
to find out who I got plenty of goon hey
what the [ __ ] and hi [ __ ] you you not do
that oh good I know I got them I got a
Kili do over here somewhere hello
you goddamn [ __ ] does your [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh god damn it ok I think the
lesson to be learned there don't take
those guys head-on at least only get one
good whap on them and then hope for the
best later because that did not go well
for me all right I'm just gonna oh yeah
good I'm up here so I can actually beat
the [ __ ] out of you
nananana okay give one good whomp it and
then the rest of them Pam baby
where'd you go where'd you go baby huh
what'd you run off to you coward now
that I know where the little figures oh
hi you're right there Oh Oh Big Bang
candy no good luck for you
Tic Tacs Oh what ah miss me it's me baby
maybe if I could reengage stealth over
and over again I'd be able to get a
little bit of a bonus there huh
that I could whoa exactly the paddywhack
whoa dog bones
whoa where you going
alrighty then and they run quick oh I
see him back there well I see you Todd
they do that quick attack what can you
do against that you can't do anything
there's literally nothing that you could
do against that hello no password found
but I can hack it I don't know what the
good what this would do but I'm going to
go for it a little sooner woody booby
booby booby and see you know I'm a
masterful hacker hello
alright you win to whomever gave dear
mr. gluing the glue face arms aka first
ships I bow to me at first I thought
that jellied eel hat could not have been
topped I stand corrected your triumphant
creation of baseball glove hands cannot
be equalled sincerely the other were the
unworthy second shift okay hello there's
a reminder if you need supplies from the
machine shop the supply closets key code
is five four seven six if you take
anything please let me know I already
broke in there sorry about that
glue adhesion uh victory of phobic okay
well that's not very useful to me but
there's another guy in here somewhere
Oh
okay then hibachi Levinsky
alrighty then can I carry on is if
nothing's bad bees there I'd be able to
pull up again
cooking with cauliflower I love
cauliflower but this isn't the time for
that alright I need to take care of this
guy and carry on with my life oh no you
don't know I'm not all beer no no no no
no no no no you don't know nothing about
me I don't know nothing about you I'm
not right damn it
don't even think about it yeah all right
I'm gonna go back with the get yield and
then I'm gonna move on because I am NOT
doing too well there hey mister operator
please kill me waiting no Seng bruising
abrasions fatigue nothing seems pretty
light browning considering hair at the
front row I'm not gonna do that okay
here we go
I know there's a way back down but I'm
just gonna try to get the drop on this
guy so I don't have to deal with him
fishing my head in know I don't know
what Beach in my head it means so
everybody shush hello ah good a banana
peel or a lemon peel or something
equally useless thank you for that hello
fatties please keep an eye on Franklin
the man spends far too much time on
personal projects and recreational
pursuits we're all human here I got it
alrighty then but a more IDI may try to
use the propulsion system to access
unauthorized areas you'd like me being
an idiot hey this is Gus down cargo bay
5 something curious in an outbound
container on my shift I think it's a
fabricator plan for an autonomous turret
who stashed with a bunch of old
capacitator cells slated for delivery to
50th facility might have been an
accident but I don't know one of the
officers put it in a safe in the life
support security station if you want it
back talk to them okay well that's good
to know
dr. Calvino isn't feeling well enough to
present the latest lookingglass tech to
our visitors so I'll be away from the
labs for an extended period I've left
everything in working order since why
I'm out but in case I'm sending you the
key code to my office 6 3 8 1 dr.
Thorstein ok alrighty then is this the
one
six sexes oh [ __ ] six three eight one
goody goody gumdrops I don't know what's
going on in here
okay uh-huh
didn't mean that Jorgen jörgen Jorgen
don't do it
Georgian you have so much to die for
Jorgen oh here we go oh you died I am
officially out of why didn't he resent
me and also do I want an asteroid
fragment that seems moderately important
I'll just drink this then gluggity
gluggity guess alrighty please tell me
you have a neuroma somewhere in here
that seems incredibly useful all right
doctor stretch you know how did I hurt
myself ah get out of here yeah okay
doctor thirsty and I just wanted to
write you personally and thank you for
the new reploid
I know some people have been 1 on
waiting lists to get one of these and it
was pleasant surprise to find a new one
in my office this morning it is this
feeling of gratitude that makes it
awkward for me to trouble you further
however if you can spare one of your
engineers for a bit it would be great if
they could swing by and show me exactly
what it does good egg WA wanted to clear
a Morgan request again Morgan was down
in Hardware today just standing there as
if not sure where to go when I offered
to help Morgan ask me for more operator
parts I asked if the last once we've
sent hadn't been sufficient and I got a
blank look I mean no offense but
Morgan's requisitioned enough to repair
any operator in the station five times
over now we have other operators that
need maintenance well I'm sorry that I'm
so I mean
that's what I was looking for that's
what I was looking for can I do i okay
so dr. Thorstein must have a co here
somewhere
uh nope mmm where oh where oh where oh
where with dr. Thorstein ah ah I see
something up there I'm gonna go up there
with a staircase of floopy doop
that's not almost there
getting it kind of domina except that
because I got no alternative ha prick a
dick hey hi I've gone there where did
you come from
Oh goddamnit no I don't think so not
today
right I might try this grand prize one
more time I know I think I think I can
get up there I think damn it damn it
hmm what if I did this oh maybe I don't
even need that
maybe I just yeah that's it ah okay fine
maybe not that but maybe if I go up here
one more try that one want to crack that
again oh yes hello are you a code no
you're afraid wire and spare parts I
thought you might have been a code up
here decide to leave decided to dick me
over fine I get it maybe I deserve a
good [ __ ] at least I got my glue gun
to keep me comfortable at night so frig
you alright so what else we got here mad
carrot nothing else there nothing else
there okay so I don't see a code here
[Music]
okay I can't find it right now so maybe
I'll find it if I keep going forward and
then I can cycle back to it I mean I
can't believe that dr. Thorstein was
also a mimic like there must be
something going on with those neurons
there has to be hello hi I'm gonna carry
on okay all right you all have a good
day goodbye I see in the next never
lucky you right I'm gonna carry back and
I'm gonna go see this looking glass
tutorial thingamabob or message for
myself but unfortunately I think the
glass might be a little bit borked
unless magically it repaired itself in
the transitional loading screens of
magic and Austen this because this
universe is filled with self repairing
materials which would be awfully nice or
then again maybe not that's just a fever
dream of me Morgan the totally human not
mimic hey where did you come from now oh
my god fine turn turn turn turn why are
you here no get away from my camp turret
no no BAM hi you sack of [ __ ] holy crap
that guy was tough oh my god okay I'll
be right back Fricka dick I don't have
enough ammo for all of this you [ __ ]
are gonna be the death of me that is for
damn sure
oh my god I get so much [ __ ] all right
I'm gonna just transfer all that but man
I need more ammo and I need it now so if
I can't make more neuro monsoon I'm just
gonna spend what I got and see if I can
get something that allow me to carry
more material because this is getting
ridiculous
I just need it I've got three yeah so I
get some muscle on my bad boy limbs and
maybe I should be able to do something
insulation an extra inventory space
yes how much more how much more we
talking here because there's three
potentials there I want to see this yes
that looks like marginally more oh I see
it does another row in a column
ah so it gets incremental II larger as
time goes on but that's already gonna be
a huge help for me cuz I got to go back
and I got to get all the goop and then
I'm gonna take care of these sons of
[ __ ] want to carry this guy I'll
bring them over here I'm gonna show
these guys 1 4 and to stop frickin
duplicating on me that they can stop
that that'd be great
I don't know where you guys went ready
to scan but where the hell do they go I
got a mysterious explosive canister that
for some reason this lovely facility
full of civilians cares around a random
Junkers in the hallway alrighty then I'm
just going to trust that this is all
honky Doodle and I'm gonna get the fudge
out here I'm gonna leave that guy there
though I don't trust that at all not at
all not even the littlest bit ok alright
ah still a little bit damaged button
oddly enough not as damaged as it once
was worse so I'm gonna turn that on
again and I'm gonna resume this cavity
wookie hello
I'm ready oh it fixed itself oh the
future is magic my glass say next
ok you have to destroy Talos 1 for
research the type and nothing can
survive including you I know how it
sounds but you've seen what those
creatures can do they're a part of you
now if even one cell gets back to earth
we're lost
I'm sorry I wish there was another way
January can walk you through activating
the self-destruct mechanism Alex will
try to stop you he's allergic to failure
too proud to go back to mom and dad with
his tail between his legs so it's up to
you now good luck told you you wouldn't
like it well I mean you were right about
one thing I didn't like him but 505 dear
I do have that code
well January what do you have to say
about Ohio hi January
I'm January twenty thirty five I'm an
operator
there are many operators aboard Talos
one none of them are like rule use over
here over here I'm looking right at you
Andy my first task was to free you from
the simulation a second task was to make
sure you saw your video those are done
interesting new directives are now
available to me
so the instruct protocol for Talos wand
is activated by two arming keys your
brother has the first you have the
second alligators droid your arming
teeth but you hit a fabrication plan for
a new one in deep storage okay that's
where you need to go next we can carry
about getting Alex's key afterwards
Nathan are spreading fast
Morgan you'll be racing against them and
your brother very hard will gain access
to the main lift and all the last the
main lift is the fastest way to reach
each storage okay alright then thank you
January really wool thank you for that
we'll take that key card you just shout
out on my desk you asked me to provide
you with more neural mods which I've
done good luck morning hmm
to assist you just why are you Russian
but I can't access them until you've
recovered both arming keys just any of
your voice it's a tactic to use your
natural suspicion I'm sure you realize
this me agent it so that you'll know I'm
earnest hey installed blank neural mods
on you that's why you can remember the
previous day's test and escape every
neural mod takes a snapshot of your
brain and models what it would look like
if you learn something new
then it makes those changes billions of
connections remapped in a matter of
minutes
mm-hmm all made possible by our friends
from outer space sube we really come
back here come back here constructed me
to sabotage the test procedures if Alex
ever failed to release you or the type
and organisms escaped containment both
happened oh why would Alex fail to
release me it seems ridiculous okay
though I'm just gonna trust like you
know what you're talking about a lot of
you might have weapons oh I think I've
already been there bro
I think I've already well been there
okay so now I can at least get rid of
something I just don't know what to get
rid of anymore I don't even know if I
need to get rid of this thing I've got
another weapon mod whoa all right I'm
gonna keep this for now because I did
get more inventory space which is going
to be good and I need more of that later
I'm sure I'm gonna make a lot more okay
but for now i doing materials and i need
to start making more bullets crap that
please thank you cuz i got a lot of a
lot of synthetic material and I got a
lot of I got a lot of DNA oddly enough
which means that I should be able to
make more neural monsoon is that make
sense that they're made out of aliens
and alien parts are the responsibility
of everything that we've got going on
here so anyway that's everything in the
seems to be in here I feel oh that was
just there
[Music]
well that wasn't obvious at all well
this was just here
well [ __ ] dude whoa [ __ ] hell
holy [ __ ] Shanker's what in the hell
Recycling's shielding's Sheila
specialized shielding makes you immune
to recycler charges okay I guess that's
good I don't know why I got that but I
guess that's good okay well I've already
upgraded this one so it's only really a
cosmetic change isn't it well it is
pretty though so I'm gonna give it that
I'll recycle the other one just because
I don't know ah but I already spent a
weapon upgrade on it ah it's gold
superior electronic gun control that
delivers the ultimate shooting
experience ah
but you know to be honest I already I
already did get the other one I did it
it says it's better but to be honest it
doesn't look like it's any better and
honestly don't so you know what I'm
sorry Margrave hey I know you look
pretty I know you're great and whatnot
and whatever but old reliable was here
first
Oh reliable has been with me since over
dinner I found or a la la vie rollable
so I'm sorry you're gonna get recycled
and I know you guys probably aren't you
happy about that but I stand by the guns
that stand by me and just because I
didn't find you doesn't mean I owe you
[ __ ]
stay there you be recycled thank you you
pooped out into these two pieces of
[ __ ] and now I got my whole suite
here and you know what just to solidify
the point just a rub some salt in the
wound I'm gonna I'm gonna upgrade this
bad boy here oh yeah oh oh ammo capacity
nah don't need that recoil oh hell yeah
oh we're gonna want some that I mean
we're gonna want less of that which is
exactly what we're gonna get when we do
that so let's keep going on all right
let's move on now that I've done what I
came here to do which is be a frickin
so now what do I need to do I need to go
on the elevator I think deep storage
locate crew member that's right I needed
to get to de Vries and de Vries seven
three to four he's in the Arboretum
which is in the elevator which I also
need to go to get felonies room key from
his body and he's in psychotronics which
means that I need to go from the lobby
to psychotronics okay and I don't know
what guts is what that seems bad but I
do need to go to the Arboretum so I'm
going to go there first and then I'll go
to Bellamy to retrieve oh they're down
there oh I'm gonna get the turret I'm a
hundred percent gonna get the turn I'm
not taking on three of those guys by my
lonesome like holy [ __ ] are they out of
their mind
no way no way in hell no I am fresh
franck in hell so I guess they must have
already taken out the turret down there
oh man this guy's crying he's so ready
to kill the planet goddamn it what
[ __ ] what how is that even fair how's
that even fair that is ludicrous oh and
this guns back you get the fudge out of
my face don't you laugh at me you get
recycled fish right so I got that where
am i go off on my way and I'm going to I
don't know maybe throw an EMP charge or
something now no idea I guess I just
need to be a little more sneaky about
this because those [ __ ] man they
mean business I just didn't even get a
chance to set this up so what I got to
do is I got to get down to the first
floor and set it up immediately it's
like the top of the stairs or something
these guys they know what the fudge is
up and what the fudge is up it's my desk
if they get closer to me down
my god how do you even how do you leave
him how do you do that how do you no no
no no oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god yeah oh my god they
hurt what the [ __ ] oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god jeez um those guys
are [ __ ] oh there's still one more
down there
those guys are giant douche head those
guys are gu sighs ha ha ha yes caliber
anyway
jeez all I didn't it didn't get
destroyed it just fell down here see if
I go it's broken nevermind broken
official sure okay adjust your attitude
there Bouch no no no no you're gonna get
gonna get blasted so hard oh ho oh ho
the [ __ ] you say Oh to shreds you say I
need to double upgrade my freakin Xiao
Shen goddamn CSUN guy yes oh I'm gonna
upgrade my Piast I'll see if I can
upgrade that range oh yeah oh yeah give
me that [ __ ] I am loyal to the weapons
with watch dots are loyal to me okay I
don't think there's another one around
here
oddly enough I don't think so so I think
I'm okay okay so I'm gonna go to the
main lift and I'm gonna go you know what
you should go back maybe I should go
back five one five zero there is that
safe and that seems pretty secretive so
I'm going to go back so I'll be right
back because I'm about to run all the
way back and you'll only see me if
something horrible happens on the way to
there but I'll be right back okay
I made it alright five one five zero I
probably get a guess that from that
because now it seems obvious but I know
it now so
I've won 5-0 Jerry oh yay oh yay what's
the potential Iser increases maximum
sign pulled by 50 I don't have any scope
chipsets so what about that then I guess
I have that now so that might have been
worth it if that's going to be really
good in the future then at least I have
that for now so anyway I'm gonna make my
way back so she whoa okay well debris
was flying out of that hole in space at
a extremely fast clip but I'm going to
carry on to the main lift and hopefully
unimpeded Lee I'm going to be able to
take that up to the Arboretum which
hasn't proved too difficult to do I
think anyway I'm gonna call that I'm
gonna go the Arboretum you having a
malfunction why what do I need to do
hello something's wrong
I'm talking to the lift control system
how because you're a robot the system is
telling me it's fine it's just the
diagnostic code is changing every time I
make a request okay it's preventing the
car from descending stuck at the top in
the Arboretum okay I can find another
way up yeah please do because I don't
think I can progress any more if you
don't follow the route to the
psychotronics lab Morgan that land is
where the type and broke containment be
careful that's okay I need to go there
anyway I kind of want to know what's
going on in the psychotronics lab who
the hell shut down the elevators and
airlock answer me
my team's locked down tight here we need
those it's working
Sam it can't be a power loss can it
thanks oh geez
Lane left and all the airlock shut down
at one value and first they give us pop
guns with us on babysitting duty then
open the gates of hell and lock us in
turn start going to need an army of
lawyers will I guess earth side anyone
else on the station get to a safe area
check your surroundings
walls floors ceilings then seal yourself
in we are working on the problem and
we'll be there to retrieve you as soon
as we can
fellas are out
okay thanks for having that conversation
on loudspeaker that's really nice I
think anyway I'm going to release this
door good morning fellas commander all
personnel must complete in monthly
monthly what you left your character
sheet on the printer don't forget we
move the game to the rec center and the
crew facilities and it's an hour later
than usual
who was the favor and take a happy pill
before showing up see you there right
turns out Eureka Maura's like everyone
else I'll tell you over lunch well I
know for a fact Yuri Kimura
is now dead but that's not my main point
that I was trying to make our enemy the
point that I can't act yet I don't have
this hacking we're heading somehow I got
to get more neural month like initially
neuro mods were just raining from the
ceiling so suddenly they just stopped
you are entering a maximum security area
that is so okay thanks December why does
everyone have code names I mean you're
not people I guess and sorry if that's
rude of me to say also I have five
neural knots when did I get five neural
mods well that's frickin awesome okay so
what am I going to do with these neuro
mods then I could get more hacking which
we've actually allowed me to be able to
hack some good stuff or get even more I
could get even more inventory space
which I always love
or I could get more hacking which seems
infinitely more useful so I'm gonna do
that yeah I can hack stuff now and then
once I'm able to craft neural mods it
won't be a problem at all I think anyway
all right but I think that's the only
thing in here so carry on my wayward son
that it's so dead space right that
reminds me of everything about dead
space even down to this like
informational panels here I mean I'm not
saying it's copying dead space in the
way I'm saying in a very pleasant way it
reminds me of dead space and I'm totally
cool with that because that is slippin
awesome man oh I wish you was more
horror right now I wish I was like
terrified out of my mind I mean this
game is us some good jump scares but in
Indiana it's still a bit more action
than it is like non action where are you
oh you're right you're right
oh dude no no cookie cookie cookie
cookie dude fam
oh god damn it Oh
got you holy jeez okay but I also like
you sheer luck that I did dad also I
need to repair my goddamn suit I totally
forgot about that
I've had these repair kits and I just
never use them maybe I should hold off
just because there might be a repair
operator around here somewhere because
that is extremely useful and I don't
want to waste them just in case I need
them in an extreme emergency but then
again what's the point of holding on to
them if I'm never gonna use a marine now
whatever all whoa I don't know what that
end maybe I shouldn't be holding it in
the palm of my hand no wave transmitter
developed in psychotronics the null wave
transmitter emits a burst of signals
which suppress the psionic ability of
anyone caught in the blast for a short
period of time it can be thrown in or
affixed to stationary objects using
mouse one okay that seems useful also
you say any person so I'm assuming that
they're going to be psychotronic people
here also why did this guy die with a
box in his ass
seems like a precarious situation to be
caught dead in one lock okay here we go
Travel okay here we go yay I'm going to
psychotronics which is something to do
with psychic ability for some reason
it's the reason that what was his name
Jeremy young the reason why his head
exploded because he was we type in
ecology in 1959 what was that we wanted
you to say I didn't read that
notification access the guts I don't
think I want to access the guts of this
ship that seems gross oh no oh no oh no
the music's taking a sour somber tone
the thing means deadliness uh maybe you
should stop guessing and we should have
a nice conversation on your brothers
messages through this place okay for me
to do utility tunnel called the guts oh
I saw all right I'll do that in just a
second I got something to do down here
there's a mimic that needs to be
disturbed oh well that was a mistake on
your part oh you're dead now so sorry
about that
nobody move I think this I'll take this
I'll take whatever you got on you mister
auto Londe so why does some of them get
turned into these horrifying burnt-out
corpses and why do some people actually
turn into straight-up physical
manifestations of the Typhon and what
did that say about first Typhon contact
in 1959 because that would change
everything because that means number one
this is a separate universe than what
one we're in
that's going alright what you thought I
was gonna shoot you or something oh
that's awfully mean of you why would you
think so lowly of me oh come on I'm just
an innocent little mimic just like you
so it may not be that I'm just a mimic
and made by me that I just have -
material inside of me and that slowly
cut erupt it might be alright gonna back
away slowly from that one I know there's
got to be some mimics here there's a lot
of these no entry signs and I don't like
it ooh a cactus with my new hacking
skills I'm such a good hacker oh that's
far away why is that gotta be so far
away - dammit dammit dammit hi-yah ex ah
yah I did it that's gonna be a son of a
[ __ ] to hack at higher levels but
probably worth it though hello yes
please our email apprehending dr.
galagos at the end of the second shift
as per Alex used direct orders you were
to escort dr. galagos to the Security
office in the main lobby so those are
Alex's orders and that was the guy who
was already dead although the
relationship between the USSR in the
United States had warmed in the past few
decades it was little doubt the vestiges
that vestiges of the iron couldn't still
hung easily between the two countries
indeed more than a century since its
inception Vladimir Lenin's communist
vision still found itself alive and well
within the oft expanded boundaries of
Mother Russia but with each new Soviet
annexation the USSR began to find the
public outcry no longer came from just
the Americans but amongst its own
citizens the Mensheviks
as they became too known oppose the
aggressive Soviet expansion doctrine
well at first only a minority the
Menshevik movement continued to grow
rapidly events would ultimately
culminate from the Soviet Indian
intervention with the outbreak of civil
unrest led by Mensheviks at the
beginning of the second purge
all righty then I don't know what I I
don't want to know what the second purge
was to be perfectly honest there I
really don't think that's the best idea
all right I'm gonna go back we got a lot
of crew here I'm looking for someone
Oh dr. galagos hi I'm looking for
Bellamy but I don't think Bellamy is
going to be here and no one has any life
signs Oh doctor agua does dr. agua is in
the cargo bay but where's the cargo bay
in relation to here oh my god how in the
world are you gonna be able to get there
I got to get the guts just to be able to
get to the cargo bay but he good a Dayo
Dayo Dayo is still alive day-o is now
egg why no one can tell me otherwise
all right but I'll get to them
eventually as soon as I find everything
that I needed here lots of more glue
which I'm assuming I need to use then
there's a mimic around here somewhere
haha God yeah God yeah
all right too bad you can't hide from me
too smart for you
hi clean room preparation okay sure
all right this
hello did someone in there I [ __ ] hi
okay that's not what I was hoping for
how we out now
okay good thing you weren't interested
in actually attacking me or else that
would've gone badly for me I want to ban
all dead and whatnot that was Crispin
for yay Crispin coior she's interesting
Trevor pulsar slammed the town's engines
and overdrive craving that war wait what
is this okay this isn't like a fictional
book yeah yeah that's total fiction
there's nothing to do therefore here
alrighty then it's got to be something
else right it's got to be something else
some secret because I can't just wander
through here and be done right there's
got to be something else to this I mean
number one I'm gonna find that mimic and
I'm gonna beat him in his stupid head
whoa hey hey you missed me do sure's no
not okay you're dead down ah that's why
I don't have the leverage to be able to
do that so I'm gonna go around the other
way
oh this is where I'm supposed to go oh
they're gonna home against all hope I Oh
put the psychic oak down psychic scope
mandatory beyond this point
oh no the sake of scope do all I know is
that when someone went in without a
second scope there had exploded that is
a giant hole on the ground I don't like
that all right hello hello hello
is there a mimic here that there is
hello
okay ah that's bad that's bad news bears
oh okay
but why though I'll take that rent drink
your ass I don't even want to know I
don't even want to know what that was
oh I don't want to think that someone
was on the toilet and that came out of
them somehow oh all right I guess I'll
go down here see what the fudge is up
down there oh that looks blocked off
maybe it's yeah oh it clear but oh I see
you punk
ha ha ha not not not not nah nah nah
okay you're all dead now
okay thank you for trying but it didn't
work out for you oh that is all right
that thing was dead I guess it was just
frozen over there and I don't think I
wrote whoo oh that was water okay hello
hello oh you don't look what what you
are you dead or are you just
oh just left that on my hand y'all do
that you're why not
is it good gather it let's go with a
breakthrough
apart from neuro mods it's the most
important tech on Talos one use it to
scan the type of organisms if you want
to learn what makes them tick you
invented it by the way
Oh oh great good I think
all right then I've acquired a chipset I
don't know how do I turn off the psycho
scope and I recall because there are but
now spawn suppress turnout desires go
close go ah oh the music is amazing
starts as my inventory swell I do need
to get to a recycler at some point I
imagine there's going to be one in the
future very nearby because they can't
just not give this to me am I right
people am I right people I'm probably
not there anything up here no there
isn't
okay alrighty then aren't carrying on
with that weird not dead guy he's just
really good at playing possum
ah I see I see I could go over there but
I can't because I'm not strong enough
well frankly I don't want to be strong
enough if that's what I need so I'm to
go back alright
hi why what's up [ __ ] how did you get a
hit on me you son of a [ __ ] I'm going
to eat these chips I'm gonna take this
shove my 20 foot up your mother loving
behind your crazy voice so don't think
you can crazy all over me when I'm gonna
gray cray all over you Clara you're you
you were you you were 100% not your you
were okay that's just a bunch of whole
team they know it
they know that blah blah blah don't even
try it
okay I got them good but I think I seem
to be stuck
I skimmed you because a friend of a
problem now okay gonna do that no okay
I'm out of bullets here here and there
I'm gonna I'm gonna get up there
eventually don't you worry
you're worried don't be I am a knight I
don't know what I was gluing but it
wasn't working I don't know what why am
I not hitting this guy with my glue ah
my face got blue stood deadly combos I
know I know I know and I forgot to put
down my psycho scope he had the high
ground Anakin I couldn't win alright
fine then it's the most important oh
okay okay I see you flap flap
okay so I got that one I need to scan
these bad boys before I'm able to kill
them because otherwise I'm not gonna get
those sweet delicious data that's all I
really care about right let's laughs
let's LARP flippity-floppity slippies
sure yeah I get this guy before he was
able to get Bank okay I guess he's not
here anymore that's weird
where are you opens all my scope
something's on my scope
something's on my screen ah
what did that do though what the hell
happened up step on okay I'm gonna get
you okay I got them scanned though so
that's good
think anyway another upgrade kit sure
I'll take that I then went a lot better
than the other way that it went to so I
need to put my Sega scope down the
entire time before I go through this
door okay I got it I don't know if I'm
always supposed to have it down it's
just kind of like a general idea my head
gonna explode the immediate second that
I take this off that's right I say maybe
fun everything seems to be on the door I
don't know what is so worried about oh
hi ribbit
did you rip manifold or forgotten what
did I do
okay all right
okay bye the psychic scope is weird
that's not his cup is weird I need to
calibrate your cycle scope
try scanning the - specimens around you
which you get enough standard the labs
will open well importantly you'll be
able to install Tyson based your mods
you'll be unstoppable
hey this is all about Morgan oh it's
been three years of life making it
possible wearing what they can do in to
us just forgotten okay alright then but
now it doesn't matter because it's cool
so wait so neurons weren't always about
putting them into us but I think that's
what the backplate neural mods thing
that's what that originally was for but
this is different this is on a whole
nother level
on a completely different level what is
that whoa
kinetic blast connecticut blast okay I
don't know what that means end review
available abilities oh I can kick on the
eyes other patterns of abilities is a
nice kinetic blast you say thanks man
I'm gonna need a lot of neurons if
you're gonna give all this to me they're
they're just doodles and caboodle Xander
Mewar ho ho ho ho when you ascend to
another plane of understanding alrighty
then that's the view oh I don't know if
I want to do
I don't know if you're gonna want that
Alex because apparently you and I have a
brotherly little rivalry that go way
beyond what you want to deal with thank
you thank you deep rumbling voice in my
ears really to appreciate that I guess
I'm not going to glean anything with a
blonde got all the data I require I
don't know what's going on over here but
guess we're gonna go get the Telstra
safe hello anything over here
alrighty then gonna just block that off
stupid electronica [ __ ] okay I got
to two key cards that's good okay time
to talk our esteemed colleague dr.
galagos is posing a problem let's talk
to you Looking Glass ASAP
dr. Kallstrom patient takagi insists she
got her hand caught in a piece of
machinery but her womb shows evidence of
bite marks human bite marks someone bit
her finger off when I add security if
they could find the finger so I could at
least reattach them they said the
Machine I ground them up what's going on
full report still pending concerning the
last experiments with V birth the Typhon
psychic cratis initially evidenced
interest in the subject but then failed
to colonize subjects mind developing a
strong aversion in fact experiment
halted at 5:01 30 minutes at M news
request 37 Center recovery well there
are seven oh thanks for the warning on
that one thank you okay well 37 has a
history of psychological instability of
the events seem to have inflicted
additional trauma both MUA you have
agreed that 37 should be held until we
can determine the origin why stop stop
that we discern the origin taesan psych
credits per your request dr. Takashi was
sent to trauma her fingers could not be
recovered was isolating continual watch
security will perform regular checks on
his physical condition okay that's weird
but I got the code here so that's good I
guess
all right thank you
got some sweetener Allods the best
noetic research like all bold new ideas
has undergone a predictable pattern in
the scientific community first skeptics
ridiculed the idea since it violates
conventional wisdom in the laws of
science second step to skeptics
grudgingly can see the idea might be
possible in some circumstances but the
evidence is weak
third the idea catches the attention of
mainstream researchers and more
importantly the public finally the same
skeptics who once laughed at the idea
now claimed that they thought of it
first
I don't even know no no no etics is but
it's not Vayu again organisms you'll be
able to install in the room on that are
powerful why did that happen we're in
this mess for one thing the station's
defense attorney was an alien threat Oh
might be worse consequences I can't yet
see oh I don't want you to lose yourself
yeah maybe I'll become an alien and
that's probably not good that probably
not good
okay so generally be careful with the
alien neural Mons I don't even know if I
need all that many I mean I can have a
few but maybe maybe I could do it all
purity style maybe I'm not actually
infected with it just yet maybe I've got
a lot of potential ahead of me oh thank
you for that you have any new ones yes
yes yes I would like that very much yes
please thank you thank you for that
Oh hold oh god no no no never that oh
man just two pieces owed all right then
so anyway with that death I will take my
leave without being bleed to death by
everything around me again I know I know
I know I know I know I know
and this can shut up they need to drop
this stuff off for I glad lab lab LA no
I know I know I know it was dangerous I
know yeah okay thanks January okay so
I'm gonna stop in this corner and I'm
gonna try to stay away from everything
horrible just trying to kill me and I
will say thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know how i'm doing the
comments below
I'm loving this as per usual I am loving
this even though I'm in the room with a
mimic right now
I will soon be among you and you can
never stop me then so thank you
everybody someone for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]